si ha sido difícil como decías pero hace
pocos minutos se ha conocido ese ganador
es el demócrata phil marfil por una por
unos votos por muy pocos votos ha sido
una contienda electoral muy ajustado
pero ya ha salido vencedor en el estado
de niños y se convierte en el primer
demócrata que ha renovado a dos
candidaturas seguidas en los últimos 44
años desde el partido demócrata han
estado pasándolo bastante malo y porque
los resultados como decía serán muy
ajustados y se han estado preguntando
qué ha podido pasar una de las razones
por las que incluye si ha podido ser tan
ajustado por los que en virginia ha
podido ganar los republicanos es porque
dicen donald también está en la casa
blanca y ese odio que transmitía donald
drama hacia los votantes demócratas no
les ha empujado a salir a las urnas que
ha habido una menor participación de la
que se esperaba también es importante
destacar que parece que ha calado entre
los ciudadanos estadounidenses el
mensaje de los republicanos en nueva
yersey por eso también han estado los
resultados más ajustados es decir esa
lucha en contra del uso de la mascarilla
esa lucha en contra de que los niños con
edad escolar se vacunen y esa bajada de
impuestos es un dato interesante también
en ver por qué esta contienda ha estado
tan reñida y porque los republicanos han
ganado en virginia es que porque parece
que empieza otra vez a tener importancia
los ciudadanos de los suburbios y hay
muchos siendo vayas sigue en virginia
ciudadanos que en el 2020 no contaron a
donald trump porque se sentían bastante
rechazo hacia él sobre todo las mujeres
y ahora cuando una transforma de la casa
blanca ha vuelto
ha vuelto a votar al lado de
usted lo reportaba entonces noticias de
último minuto victoria para los
demócratas en nueva jersey y victoria
para los republicanos en virginia como
se interpretan estos resultados de cara
a los comicios de 2022
si es claramente un termómetro de lo que
va a pasar en esos comicios del 2022 lo
que hemos visto hoy es que esa victoria
de joe biden hace un año exactamente que
se producía ha ido perdiendo adeptos yo
voy de ahora mismo tiene un índice de
aprobación de un 42 por ciento eso es 15
puntos menos de lo que tenía en enero y
esto lo hemos visto reflejado en estas
elecciones no lo que nos muestra
claramente es que es una llamada de
atención muy clara que ojo porque los
demócratas podrían perder esa mayoría en
el congreso en los comicios del 2022 o
incluso perder la casa blanca en el 2024
va a ser una tarea nada fácil joe biden
sufre dentro de su propio partido en esa
lucha por aprobar ese plan de gasto
social e infraestructuras y además pues
también estamos viendo que en el entorno
político del país vuelve a inclinarse un
poco hacia los republicanos que han
conseguido dar en la clave con los temas
que interesan a los ciudadanos en todo
el tema de la pandemia a la recuperación
económica a los altos precios en la
comida y en la gasolina y el auto índice
de que en realidad algunas ciudades de
eeuu